[Music]
hey everyone and welcome back to game
Sports coverage of e3 2018 I'm Lucy
James joined by Mike Mahadi we're here
on the show floor giving you all the
biggest games from this year's show
including live demos so make sure you
stick with us all week we're gonna kick
off today day date 2 of the show proper
I guess we could call it we're gonna
kick off with call of duty black ops for
joining us from Treyarch is miles Leslie
miles thank you so much for joining us
thanks for having me how is your show
going so far I think it's going well
we've got a good crowd coming out people
are coming out and playing getting
pretty excited so I think the team scene
that's getting energized as well just
get that momentum coming out so that
means the huge big change is you guys
are switching up the way you're doing
single player multiplayer you talk a
little bit more about how single player
well it's kind of gone like how is that
gonna work
absolutely so for us at Treyarch we've
always kind of been in the business of
doing non-traditional stories it's kind
of in our DNA going back to reeben world
at war black ops 1 and black ops 2 black
ops 3 it's all about how to tell a
different story
black ops 4 is no exception we came in
trying to tell a very different story
really trying to make a social game and
what we've tried to do is like
interweave the narrative throughout
multiplayer and these solo missions as
well that you can learn about the
specialist zombies you got the brand-new
cast as well returning cast a lot more
sort of going on there and then on top
of all that you've got brand new black
out as well there's sort of a
celebration Battle Royale really black
ops style and where the Battle Royale
was that like an effort to you know like
battle royale games are doing well now
is that more an effort to kind of just
get in on the trend or did you guys know
you want to do something similar to that
for a while or what was the situation
there I mean we're gamers right and for
the last year it's like you play these
games and have a lot of fun and you're
always kind of talking like what if or
what's the cool idea but I think what's
really strong at Treyarch is we're all
about doing the right idea that kind of
does service to what we want to do and
so we really didn't want to do anything
unless we could really make it uniquely
ours and really distinguished ourselves
from the other body rail games so I
think it crystallized earlier this year
we had this idea of really a celebration
a sandbox of really this library of the
last 10 years because we have a huge
library of just different content
let's put that in let's let players
really have a battle experience where
you know you can drive an RC XD you can
use zombies characters zombies weapons
old MP weapons single-player weapons
just throw everything in that players
love in a new way and its really work
like the problem we have now actually is
that people are playing it too much of
the studio and that's when you know
you've got something really special so
we're pretty excited about it I was
gonna say going through the catalog of
black ops games how do you pick and
choose what to bring obviously you've
got the fan favorites but other things
of the studio that you guys are like now
we really love that bit that bit has to
come yeah absolutely it's it's really
hard over the 10 years when you start
looking at all the different content
there's so much is you try to weigh in
with what's right for the experience and
the balance as well you know you have to
you got to give the fans what they want
but you can't really deliver it in a way
where they wouldn't have fun so that
always has to get checked design wise
and we feel like we've got a good
balance the main thing is just plate
size play test play test and iterate as
much as possible to backtrack to the
battle rail quick what is it about
blackout that's setting it apart from
you know like fortnight from pub G from
other games that might like use this
mode so to speak yeah for us I mean I
think what really distinguishes sort of
black ops and Call of Duty is that the
feel of the guns right at first per
person brady feel you feel the weight of
the weapons you feel the weight of sort
of using all your equipment and
abilities in that connection to that
weapon is for us we think something
that's unparalleled so we're excited to
bring that into battle royale with
blackout and then again with all the
different you know hey people love
newtown well now you're gonna experience
newtown in a new way and blackout oh hey
you love to raid
here's raid in a new way as well as
we've got this legacy that really no one
can compete with us on is that we're
gonna deliver this in a really an
interesting way overall and speaking of
guns like you guys have to be will you
be rebalancing them yeah had to like how
they were in like the original black ops
oh absolutely the big thing for the team
was how do we take all the weapons and
really deliver a new system where you're
gonna add more depth to it so each of
the weapons we've got now predictive
recoil and what that allows is for you
to it's more skill based is that if you
want you can learn how a gun is going to
fire and you can try to master it and
that's a huge thing for us for the
weapons as well as each
one has its own personality we really
want players to be attached to weapons
and want to take that weapon and really
get in arguments over weapons oh hey no
the this guns better no you're wrong
this one's better so each of each gun
has its own set of attachments so that
people they want to pick that weapon
that weapon sort of personifies them so
you've been at Treyarch you were saying
for like ten years now yeah when you
finish black ops three and then you know
you like before Lee while Infinity Ward
was working on called duty and
sledgehammer working on Call of Duty and
you know Treyarch went back to the
drawing board to say what do we want to
do next
did you know that it would be a black
ops again or at what point did you know
you're gonna do black ops four and it
wasn't gonna be some new series in the
Call of Duty franchise yeah that was a
tough one because it's never like you
immediately know because it you already
you're still supporting black ops three
I mean for us we love supporting the
community and and this community's
really supported us so black ops three
it was really our focus was on that and
it really you know you don't crystallize
them til you start thinking about well
okay what do we start doing next what
how can we really challenge and elevate
what we've done before and it's the team
really responds to okay you did that
well throw it away and how do you do it
again but even better and that's when
you talk about the weapons okay let's
rebuild these let's break down every
single component okay hey the health
model let's redo the health model which
has never been done before and Call of
Duty hired you know ttk talked about
time to kill longer engagement some more
tactical approach to game and really get
that layering it kind of seemed like a
natural progression for us of where to
take it because we've been you know ten
years of Call of Duty in black ops that
the team kind of latched on to it very
easily like let's let's make these very
hard and very significant changes
because it was right are you worried at
all about reception from you know like a
community you'll get used to things and
they'll the like things the way they are
and if you change things sometimes might
not always be met with the excitement
that yeah absolutely I mean I think
we're all a little nervous when you you
change something that's so fundamental
like the health stuff for example and
you Kyle is this the right call but as
soon as you play the game you know it's
the right call and that's the main thing
here at e3 and you know when we had the
reveals we got to get the game into
people's hands and get people talking
about it and really evangelize it for us
cuz as soon as you play the game you
know why it was the right decision
right
that's the main thing is that it plays
differently it plays better in our eyes
you know really an evolution are you
saying it's been 10 years of zombies
yeah what kind of celebration are we
gonna be expecting in black ops 4 yes
for zombies fans we've got three brand
new experiences day one biggest offering
I've ever had
brand new cast of characters brand new
storylines but on top of all that on the
day one experience is we're really
trying to add a way for new players to
come in right as a'm be can be
overwhelming because what the zombies
team and jason blundell do is bonkers
that's okay but we need to need a way to
bring in new players and that's been
something that the community has talked
about and really tried to pour a lot
into is that what the difficulties are
back there's a way now that you can
bring new players in and kind of hey let
me show you how to do the quest all the
crazy stuff I'm gonna get you to love
that stuff too so I think zombies fans
are gonna be pretty excited because each
of those different levels different
experience as far as multiplayer goes so
black ops 2 if my memory serves was the
introduction of pic 10 right and then I
don't know they like that almost maybe
it's not perfected as a right word but
like how do you build on multiplayer
after like a yearly release SS it seems
like Call of Duty has figured it out
it's I imagine it must be a challenge to
improve upon what isn't broken to begin
with it absolutely is you're kind of in
this frame of you need to preserve that
Call of Duty Black Ops feel and that's
sort of magic which pick-ten how the
weapons feel but you have to absolutely
push and innovate as much as possible
and the team is always taking on that
challenge like okay migratory my weapons
were good doing better all right and
they kind of jump into that so you talk
about the pick 10 is okay pick tens back
how do you make it new interesting how
do you make the choices more meaningful
than they've ever been before so you
start talking about the weapons and how
they're person that you know really
personal to you if the attachments that
are on them the choices you're making
from the perks to the new equipment -
you know specking in to have the
specialist ability all that adds a lot
of depth and layering that we haven't
had before let's talk a little bit about
the PC release so obviously so on that
trailer you guys have been working with
the overwatch team had a little bit from
Jeff and it's gonna be on the Blizzard
client father we're super excited about
that so for us about doing PC
really just this is if you know it's not
a port we've been working up with B NOx
really supporting us and trying to
deliver a PC experience that PC fans are
really gonna enjoy and love and that's
been a huge thing for us as we've heard
the community and we're trying to push
as much as possible to deliver that PC
true experience that they that they
really expect and they deserve and
that's where we want to get back to them
so the team is they've done a lot a lot
of dials and knobs at PC players want so
we think they're gonna be excited and
blizzards been really awesome about
putting it on battlenet and you know
when you get the Blizzard sort of seal
of approval that it's good enough to go
on battlenet I mean that that says it
all on top of the black ops you know so
what are you gonna if I'm playing on
battlenet am I gonna be able to play and
like talk to my friends who may be
playing overwatch or destiny at the same
time I'm not sure to be honest with you
yeah the PC team they if I said anything
that was not right they would they would
kill me the PC crowd was yes I'm curious
we're just watching the game plan you
mentioned increasing the time to kill
when I think Call of Duty and I think
when most people think all do you think
of accessible like QuickTime - yeah like
I could jump in if this is my first time
playing called dirty I could jump in and
kill a veteran I'd have a chance
increasing time to kill did you were you
worried that you were making a game that
wasn't really called duty anymore
yeah it's interesting because it's by
actually increasing the health what we
found is you get in longer fights which
is actually good for casual fans because
they're not they're not getting kind of
you know killed instantly right it can
kind of assess what's going on they can
try to get away they can use some of the
new healing or some of the equipment to
heal faster slide away so it's actually
made engagements more meaningful and and
there's more thought behind it so casual
fans and we've done user testing and
play testing has they've responded
really well to I actually can make
meaningful choices and when I get in a
fight and I lose I don't feel like I
lost because that guy was better at me
with his gun he just kind of
outmaneuvered me and stayed in the fight
long or I made a better decision so we
feel like it actually might help casual
fans but also has that layering that you
know hardcore and and loyal fans going
back and even the pro level there's a
lot of depth there but that change it
was super scary yeah we did it and
everyone was like what are you doing
yeah wait don't do that I'm just
watching people yeah yeah 10 seconds I
you notice I mean between
the health bar and the actual firefights
I'm like this is actually like not a
split second and I yeah and the cool
thing there is that it's more rewarding
now when you get a kill and also when
you survive yeah right so it's not like
you're saying I turn a corner I'm dead
now I turn the corner get hit okay
let me try to figure out a way to get
out of here and I feel like I survived I
feel like that badass that you know
every player wants to be and we've kind
of given them that with all these
changes I mean like what do you think
are the core pillars you have to bring
from each black ops game into a new one
that's tough you know it's it's like for
us it's it's all about the weapons right
that is the number one thing got to do
justice to the weapon feel really
rewarding the player and what gun
they've picked and they've done the team
has done an amazing job of like you know
you got the smoke on the barrel after it
shoots and really hearing each of the
mechanisms and the audio and really just
making sure that you understand what
this weapon is and and why it's unique
so guns sort of guns up in guns
mentality number one and then also the
the new is the depth you take all these
different the content and look at the
content from the over the last ten years
and you pick and choose what's going to
add so that that sort of tactical depth
that we've got so you're making more
meaningful impactful choices as you play
the game and and you add in all that and
it's just there's a lot of layers to it
now I was also curious I mean with
working with Infinity Ward and
sledgehammer and Treyarch obviously the
three studio rotation I imagine there's
friendly competition but what are some
things from like infinity ward or
sledgehammer specifically maybe with
world war two or something that you
maybe borrowed or thought worked really
well that would fit into tray arcs work
with black ops it you know it's it's
tough as we it's definitely it's like
they're our sister studios and we want
them to succeed and we'll help each
other out as much as possible like
consulting hey come check out this new
feature but everyone's really heads down
so you kind of in a way just going and
doing your own thing because you don't
have time to kind of look at their thing
if that makes sense but you know the war
mode they did was really cool and and
how do you do a new game mode and that
kind of inspired hey let's do the
control and some of this other stuff is
players want new experiences so you kind
of look at everywhere you know the other
Call of Duty's other games and how do
you build upon that
it's never it's never like hey let's sit
down and go through all your features
and see what we can take crafting your
own experience right and that's the man
that you want it to stand apart because
players can they could feel that that it
the games feel different and that's done
on purpose right let's talk a little bit
about the specialist so Who am I gonna
be able to play what am I gonna be able
to do yeah so specialists are back in a
big way they each have their own
specialist you know abilities they're
kit now is really fine-tuned to sort of
give them a role right we have a scene
in the studio do your job and it's all
about the specials do your job so ruin
returns and his job really is about
rushing in so he's got the grapple gun
so he can get in super quick and he can
combo to the grab slam and that's all
for people if they want to be a rusher
so if you're you know you're a slayer
obviously you're gonna get like a 60 no
kills you're gonna want to take ruin and
you want to get in there basically I'm
not very good maybe and so I'm gonna
take crash and crash is brand new and
he's gonna be able to heal so I'm gonna
support you so I'm gonna throw down an
assault pack you're gonna pick that up
and then you're gonna go ham and you're
gonna get me score basically and we're
both going to benefit from us supporting
each other right and then if you're in a
firefight getting getting hit I can heal
you right which is a brand new thing as
well so it's all about these
relationships and sort of the
connectedness of the specialists it's
really huge and that's where you get the
layering I mean in the studio we get
arguments now of like what the perfect
composition of specialists is like now
you gotta have torque if you don't have
torque you're doing it wrong no man you
need crash no not crash you got to have
this and that's when you know you're
doing something that is really special
because everyone has their own opinion
on it and that's why we're excited when
it goes out to kind of see the meta from
the casual hardcore even the pro level
that's not to be reductive ending but it
sounds like you're kind of leaning more
into like being a hero based shooter
with regards to the specialist something
like overwatch where it is teamwork
makes the dream work really would you
say that's like you're in yeah we don't
we don't look at it as a hero sure it's
more about making sure that it's it's
teamwork right say you can still be
right Call of Duty is all about still
being you can lone wolf if you want ya
can still be a badass but if you team up
you actually be more successful and
we're encouraging that more and more
well you talk about the mini-map changes
with fog of war now you can actually see
what your teammates see around them
let's do encourage you to stay together
talk and communicate and going back to
the sort of the why the team works
important is people now when we play
it's not even when if I'm yelling at you
I'm actually yelling to do your job okay
go put that razor wire down and it's
actually 14 communication because you
have a job I got a job when we got to do
that and so the teamwork has kind of
come out naturally is that hey we need
to do these things together if we really
want to be successful and we've crafted
maps around that all right so it's like
choke points and different avenues to
flank for sort of the different
specialists to really encourage the
unique play and the vast different
playstyles that we've got well miles
thank you so much for joining us when we
get our hands on black ops for October
12th that's when it comes out you get
everything awesome it thank you so much
for joining us all right guys make sure
to stay tuned if you're watching at home
because coming up we're gonna have over
cooked to seeing a few
[Music]
you
[Music]